royales ist zurückgetreten es ist
rücktrittszeit hier eine Liste von
Dingen wer auch noch dringend
zurücktreten sollte Leute die Filme nach
erzählen nein ich habe den Film nicht
gesehen ich möchte ihn noch sehen hör
auf damit alle Leute die mich an der
Kasse fragen ob ich Punkte sammle nein
Leute die ihr Handy auf laut stellen das
ist 90er Schild es gibt Vibrationsalarm
nutze ich andreas Scheuer dafür dass er
den Start 243 Millionen Euro kostet
sollte er mindestens 10 mal Zurücktreten
der Mond brauche ich persönlich nicht in
der Nacht finde ich komisch außerdem
macht er das ist mehr weg ist man hat
immer nur das halbe Meer da steht man
dann und denkt sich ich hatte für das
Ganze mehr bezahlt warum ist hier nur
die Hälfte da ach ja ich muss noch 8
Stunden warten